Véronique prince Hélène buzetti elle est
castongué bonsoir
bonsoir
inévitable comme sujet incontournable et
feux de forêt je fais entendre monsieur
Legault et Monsieur Trudeau
par contre faut être prudent c'est pas
une explosion là par rapport à ce qu'on
a déjà vu certaines années il y a des
années qu'il y en a eu beaucoup des
années qu'il y en a eu moins donc faut
être prudent comparé juste à la moyenne
puis dire à toute la croissance de cette
année toute dû au changement climatique
il y a aussi des années où il y en a
plus que d'autres mais comme
j'expliquais il y a une tendance quand
même en moyenne à ce qui est de plus en
plus
mais en plus de tout simplement rebâtir
il va falloir qu'on réfléchisse à
rebâtir en mieux aussi de s'assurer
qu'on est cette réflexion en même temps
qu'on est en train de d'accroître le
logement et créer des plus de communauté
résidentielles à travers le pays qu'on
réfléchisse au défi qui vont venir avec
plus de d'événements météorologiques
extrêmes et plus de feux de forêt dans
les années à venir
parce que si on dit si on reconnecte ce
sont les changements climatiques là en
grande partie ça veut dire il faut
s'organiser mieux pour les prochaines
fois là c'est un peu ça l'idée oui
exactement et là il y a cette discussion
de footing y avoir une espèce de
d'escadron je ne sais pas trop comment
l'appeler fédérale qui serait mis à la
disposition des provinces c'est pas
évident que ce soit de ça dont on a
besoin est-ce que compte tenu des
prédictions futures on aura plus de feux
et donc un besoin accru de ressources il
semblerait que oui et auquel cas que les
organismes tel la soft feu s'adressent à
leur maître politique respectifs pour
demander le quotient des ressources
supplémentaires mais est-ce que ces
ressources supplémentaires doivent être
gérées par Ottawa ça c'est un autre
enjeu il existe déjà cette ce centre
inter service des feux de forêts du
Canada qui est déjà un organisme de
coordination des différentes entités au
Canada qui est aussi en contact avec son
équivalent américain et qui fait déjà
cette espèce de veille et de déplacement
en fonction des priorités des ressources
en canadiennes alors je suis pas
convaincu qu'on a besoin kotawa mette
davantage son nez là-dedans mais
peut-être oui que des ressources des
avions et puis évidemment je suis pas la
personne pour juger de ça des avions
supplémentaires ou des ressources seront
supplémentaires pour le futur
plus dans chaque province soit un peu
mieux équipé ici c'est pour arriver plus
souvent quoi
je pense que la clé elle est là que ce
soit chacune des provinces qui soit
mieux équipées plutôt que le fédéral qui
arrive dans le dossier puis qui ajoute
une couche supplémentaire de complexité
quand on a besoin de l'armée canadienne
elle est là maintenant ce que la
sockfurde doit être mieux financée mieux
se préparer oui probablement parce que
aura plus de travail mais en général
elles performe bien la Sauveur quand on
regarde les dernières années c'est
arrivé plus souvent où la soif a prêté
des pompiers forestiers à d'autres
juridictions au Canada aux États-Unis
que l'inverse on a donc assez rarement
besoin d'aide on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle on a besoin d'aide des
autres provinces peuvent pas venir nous
aider parce que des fois en
Nouvelle-Écosse au niveau bondué quand
on a mis britannique en Alberta on est
rendu à faire appel à la France à
l'Australie la Nouvelle-Zélande mais
c'est très rare c'est la soft feu qui
donne un coup de main ça veut dire que
l'organisme est bien géré et performant
mais faudra effectivement qu'il le
demeure donc ce qu'on doit augmenter le
nombre de policiers ce qu'on doit
s'équiper en avion au système c'est
l'ouverture des avions austernes on les
obtient pas six mois plein de
capitalisation donc peut-être voir tout
ça pour qu'on soit prêt à l'avenir et
d'être même quand il y a des
catastrophes peut-être plus aiguë qu'on
soit pas obligé d'avoir besoin de nos
partenaires les Européens qui appellent
ça encore les canadaires parce que dans
ce n'est plus
bombardier avait vendu c'est encore levé
britannique la maison mère mais c'est
l'ancêtre des Canadairs donc ce
magnifique avion qui va chercher de
l'eau Véronique quand même monsieur
Legault avait sonné quand même un peu
inquiétant on a eu chaud en fin de
semaine là c'est le cas de le dire le
Bel sur Quévillon c'est pas ses proches
puis d'autres en Abitibi il pleut pas
cette semaine c'est délicat là
et c'était imprévisible alors le rôle du
gouvernement et de François Bonnardel
c'est de prendre son téléphone de dormir
avec de surveiller la situation dort en
arbre convaincu qu'il le fait en ce
moment là et de répondre présent quand
son téléphone sonne parce que c'est
important de faire la distinction entre
le rôle du gouvernement puis le rôle sur
le terrain des gens qui sont en train de
combattre ces feux là je une anecdote
par rapport à ça mais je veux pas je
veux protéger ma source alors je vais
dire dans un ancien gouvernement dans
une ancienne catastrophe semblable un
ministre avait voulu survoler en
hélicoptère il avait voulu noliser
l'appareil pour survoler les dégâts en
disant je vais mieux comprendre la
situation sur le terrible je vais
pouvoir mieux communiquer alors c'était
parti d'une bonne intention plus la
sécurité civile sécurité publique avait
appelé au Conseil exécutif avait dit là
gérer vos ministres parce qu'on peut pas
assurer votre sécurité on est dans le
jus par-dessus la tête comme on dit vous
viendrez en appui et en renfort quand on
va vous le demander alors tout ce qui
est décision opérationnelle sur le
la sécurité civile ce sont des
professionnels ils sont habitués ils
connaissent leur affaires mais quand ils
ont besoin d'avoir plus de ressources
que ce soit plus d'équipements de
l'équipement plus moderne aussi plus de
personnels plus de moyens financiers
c'est là où le gouvernement doit
intervenir doit leur fournir et c'est
aussi le rôle du gouvernement de faire
le pont avec les autres provinces ou les
autres pays puis le gouvernement fédéral
puis s'assurer que quand il y a le temps
de prendre des décisions politiques sont
là mais pour tout ce qui est
opérationnel c'est pour ça que vous avez
pas vu monsieur Legault à cette cylo en
Abitibi aujourd'hui
ça va arriver là vous allez le voir sur
le terrain mais quand il va être sur le
terrain c'est parce qu'on va lui avoir
dit correct tu peux venir tout le monde
va être en sécurité très bien autre
sujet j'ai moins de temps je vous le dis
je m'excuse déjà en partant j'ai moins
de temps aujourd'hui à cause des feux on
écoute Bernard drinville il lui faut
mieux enseigner le français dans les
écoles au Québec faut que les
secondaires 5
réussissent davantage on écoute on
revient
il y a pas de recette magique
mais le message qu'on envoie aujourd'hui
c'est que l'enseignement et
l'apprentissage du français c'est une
priorité pour pour notre société et
qu'on peut pas se permettre de regarder
les résultats des gringolées comme on
l'a vu lors des dernières examens du
ministère il faut un redressement il
faut que tout le monde mette la main à
la pâte
effectivement les résultats ont
dégringolé je vous donne un tableau très
très court 2019
79% de réussite 2022 69 donc des
gringolées
Alec donc on ne sait pas encore il dit
je vais mandater des gens qui
connaissent ça mais je sais qu'on fera
quelque chose
bon d'abord je peux vous annoncer la
première conclusion de ce comité
d'experts qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
2019 et 2022 ah il y a eu une pandémie
il y a eu l'école à distance et c'est
quoi les trois dans les trois critères
d'évaluation que le plus souvent du côté
des élèves parce qu'ils comprennent
encore très bien les textes sont encore
très bien capables de faire de la
compréhension de lecture ce qui est
difficile c'est l'orthographe ben oui
l'orthographe la grammaire ça se
pratique pas mal en classe pas mal plus
difficile de convaincre des jeunes
devant un écran de faire leur table de
grammaire puis faire des dictée alors je
peux déjà vous dire que ça ça a eu un
grand impact probablement une bonne
partie du 10 points de base et donc
normalement les corps les plus affectés
vont progressivement traverser leurs
années primaires et être capable et
secondaire et éventuellement on devrait
retrouver quelque chose qui ressemble à
80%, il sait pas les profs ont pas
arrêté d'enseigner le français par
rapport à ce qu'il faisait avant il y a
eu clairement là un événement est-ce que
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas se
préoccuper de l'état du français non je
pense que c'est une bonne idée de revoir
tout ça ça fait longtemps qu'on l'a pas
fait prof de français la demande aussi
comment incarner le français dans
différentes matières pas seulement en
français mais capable de pratiquer le
français dans pleine matière très bonne
idée mais moi je ne serai pas je vais
pas le réseau de l'éducation à l'envers
pour une baisse de 10 points qui sont
devenu pendant la pandémie je pense que
l'explication elle est pas mal là mais
une volonté de lire davantage d'écrire
davantage lire davantage aussi
la littérature québécoise en fait dans
le communiqué il y a toutes sortes de
choses Hélène oui j'ai participé il y a
quelques semaines à un coloc à
Sherbrooke de Mauze et de craie qui
rassemble en fait des enseignants
essentiellement du primaire et du
secondaire qui ont la passion
d'enseigner l'écriture aux jeunes mais
justement parler par le fait d'écrire en
classe et plusieurs me racontait que le
problème c'est ça c'est qu'on s'attend à
ce que nous nos jeunes performent lors
des examens ou d'une dictée ici et là
mais il ne se pratique jamais
au quotidien à l'école c'est comme de
demander à quelqu'un de faire un
marathon mais qui plus jamais entraîné
auparavant ça va être difficile ce sera
stressant et donc il faut revenir à
cette écriture
soutenue fréquente régulière certains
parlent de la dictée les gens que j'ai
fréquentés là-bas oui mais pas
nécessairement ça peut être seulement
des ateliers d'écriture de racontez-moi
ce que vous avez fait en fin de semaine
quel est un de vos rêves vos voyages
mais de faire en sorte que écrire
devienne une routine quelque chose qu'on
fait régulièrement on se corrige le soir
peut-être même soi-même mais c'est comme
ça qu'on devient bon c'est en s'exerçant
on a beaucoup parlé on a pointé du doigt
bon l'immigration des gens dans la
communauté anglophone qui voulaient pas
faire d'efforts mais chez les
francophones il y a un bout de chemin à
faire à la base c'est de d'effectivement
s'assurer que les jeunes apprennent les
écrivent bien le français parce que
c'est vrai ce qu'alect disait il y a un
instant ils sont tellement devant leur
écran que vous allez remarquer par
exemple que le pronom démonstratif c'est
c'est apostrophe est il y en a beaucoup
qui vont écrire juste la lettre C c'est
écrit beaucoup en abrégé puis ça aussi
c'est inquiétant alors le gouvernement
logo ne peut pas juste parler
d'immigration puis de la communauté
anglophone mais de ne pas non plus faire
l'effort du côté francophone pour
s'assurer que les jeunes suivent aussi
et est-ce que ça va se préciser bientôt
un tour de table rapide avec parce que
là ce Draveil a dit je vais demander des
gens que ça puis est-ce que on va voir
ça bientôt aller là c'est pour la
rentrée scolaire 2025 donc c'est pas
septembre c'est pas septembre prochain
c'est septembre dans deux ans donc il
faut que le comité arrive avec ses
conclusions il faut qu'on mette tout ça
en place donc on verra pas de
modification dans le cursus scolaire ou
dans la pédagogie avant au moins deux
ans Hélène et même ce calendrier moi il
m'apparaît ambitieux dans la mesure où
c'est un sujet extrêmement sensible qui
est toujours l'objet de grande
controverses plus de dictée moins de
dictée on se déchire là on a vu déjà les
syndicats d'enseignants
consultez nous nous on le sait etc ça
m'apparaît très très rapide même si
c'est loin là ça m'apparaît rapide de
comment mission Véronique mais c'est un
peu paradoxal parce que le gouvernement
a toujours dit avec des consultations
on perd du temps puis ils ont toujours
été contre les consultations les forums
qui s'éternisent quand ils étaient dans
le position mais Bernard Dreville c'est
vrai qu'il est dans une position où il
peut pas prendre la décision une année
puis il faut quand même qui consulte les
gens qui sont sur le terrain parce que
lui-même est pas un expert en la matière
il est devenu ministre par la force des
choses puis il apprend mais il doit
consulter les gens sur le terrain puis
c'est sûr ça prend un petit peu plus de
temps dans ce temps là
très bien mais ça a été sauf erreur ça a
été bien accueilli par l'association des
enseignants de français avec on a je
sais pas si vous l'aviez entrevue ou
j'ai vu un film
ça fait un petit moment eux qui plaisent
pour une révision là du cursus la
manière dont on intègre le français donc
ça c'est plus son content de voir que
enfin on se préoccupe la situation on va
parler un autre foi de la cour
porte-parole de Québec solidaire ça va
se régler de toute façon cet automne
mais on va on va on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler Véronique Hélène Alec prochaine
fois plus de temps promis au revoir
au revoir